roseann loses her sitcom after a racist
tweet kim kardashian heads to the white
house and we discussed the biggest news
story nobody's talking about i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
we are very excited to be back in our
home Studios here in Los Angeles by the
way if you have not yet gone and bought
tickets to our events in Dallas in
Phoenix the tickets are selling out fast
those happen in August kodály wired.com
slash events to check it out before I
jump into the news and plenty of news
there is as always first I want to say
thanks to our sponsors over at Birch
gold so you know because I've said it a
thousand times
the reality is you should have at least
some of your finances in gold you should
have some in precious metals because of
volatility in the market because of the
government's tendency toward inflation
when things get tough because of the
stock market moving up and down
yesterday the stock market dropped
nearly 400 points well one thing that is
a little bit less volatile is precious
metals is never more zero and that means
that if you invest in precious metals
you are guaranteeing at least a
percentage of your income against the
vicissitudes of the market and
government intervention ISM that's why
you should talk to my friends over at
Birch gold group well they have a
long-standing track record record of
secant in you´d success thousands of
satisfied clients countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau and if you contact Birch
gold group right now you can request a
free information kit on physical
precious metals this comprehensive 16
page kit reveals how gold and silver can
protect your savings how you can legally
move your IRA or 401k out of stocks and
bonds into a precious metals IRA if you
choose to do so to get that no-cost
no-obligation kit all you have to do is
go to birchgold.com slash Bend and
that's birchgold.com slash Ben they're
the folks I trust with precious metals
investing birchgold.com / Ben use that
slash Ben so they know that we sent you
so I'm not going to say I told you so
I'm not going to say I warned you I'm
not going to say that I was the voice
calling out in the wilderness Roseanne
is not a conservative don't trust her
don't follow her no don't come back stop
I won't say that I said any of those
things I said all of those things okay I
told you hey Roseanne is a crazy person
Rosen has been a crazy person for years
she ran with Cindy Sheehan and on one of
these Indy Party nomination tickets she
took a picture of herself with a hit
little mustache putting little cookies
in the oven that were supposed to be
Jews hey Roseanne is a crazy person she
being a crazy person for a long time and
just because she's a crazy person who
happens to like Trump a lot more than
some other crazy people that does not
mean that she was ever an ally of
conservatives while she demonstrated why
it is bad to embrace volatile celebrity
who happen to be crazy just yesterday
when she decided it would be a great
idea to start tweeting about Valerie
Jarrett in the most insane possible way
so here is what she tweeted about
Valerie Jarrett Valerie Jarrett of
course was the kind of unsung
chief-of-staff to Barack Obama I am NOT
a Valerie Jarrett fan I think Valerie
Jarrett is an awful person but Valerie
Jarrett is also not what Roseanne says
she is here okay so Roseanne says Muslim
Brotherhood and Planet of the Apes had a
baby equals Valerie Jarrett okay so
number one that's disgusting
that's horrifying you shouldn't be
calling black people Apes I mean I
thought there's basically like one rule
in the media that you cannot violate if
you wish to survive and Roseanne Barr
took that landmine and jumped on it with
both feet and then just in case it
didn't go off she jumped on it again
with both feet so she says she she
compares Valerie Jarrett to an ape which
is just disgusting and horrifying
especially given the long history in
this country of comparing black people
to two Apes which is just awful and
horrifying in every possible way and
then Roseanne show is dropped so she
tweets this and then her show dies right
so ABC pulls her show it was the
number-one sitcom on television so they
presumably lost some money on this thing
but it wasn't like ABC didn't know that
Roseanne was a crazy person when they
hired her they knew the risks involved
when they hired they bought the ticket
they took the ride and Roseanne provided
them that ride we'll talk in a second
about when it is appropriate for
corporations to crack down on so-called
free speech and I say so-called because
free speech issues are really only
implicated when the government is
involved if the government cracks down
on your free speech like Tommy Robinson
in the UK as we discussed yesterday
that's a free speech issue but when it's
a private corporation taking a measure
to protect its own products I'm not
quite sure it's the same thing in fact
I'm sure it's not the same thing
in any case Roseanne tweets this thing
out her career is over
she's toast goodbye to Roseanne and
frankly from my perspective a little bit
good riddance I understand a lot of
conservatives we're very happy that
Roseanne show did not treat Trump
supporters as evil nasty terrible people
the problem is that what Roseanne did
just allowed the left to treat all Trump
supporters as evil nasty terrible people
Chris Hayes for example over on MSNBC he
tweeted this out this 15 May he tweeted
out quote Roseanne's problem turned out
to be that she far too authentically
represented the actual world view of
significant chunk of the Trump base now
he has no basis for setting this he has
no basis for saying that a significant
chunk of president Trump's base thinks
that black people are Apes or the
Valerie Jared is a mash up of the Muslim
Brotherhood and Planet of the Apes has
no data to support this but it doesn't
matter
roseann just provided a crowbar for the
left to whack people with which is
really just wonderful thing to do and
the left jumped on it with alacrity so
Valerie Jarrett of course responded and
she responds it by ripping into
president Trump and talking about
everyday racism in America I do have to
point out that this clip from MSNBC is
extraordinary for a couple of reasons
one I just want you to look at this
panel okay look at this panel so you got
chris hayes right who's the who's the
guy sitting right there who just said
that trump's base supports this kind of
stuff and then next to him you have joy
reid okay joy reid is a person who just
a couple of weeks ago nearly lost her
job because it turns out that she'd
written a bunch of posts that were
deemed homophobic and offensive and
anti-semitic and all this stuff and she
claimed that she didn't write them and
then she claimed that she had amnesia
and she claimed that she was hacked okay
and joy reid is still sitting on the set
now talking about the stuff that
roseanne tweeted so just to be straight
here roseanne tweet something loses her
job joy read tweets stuff that's really
gross not only maintains her job gets to
sit on set with valerie jarrett
discussing the evils of twitter racism
so there's that and then sitting next to
valerie jarrett on the other side is al
Sharpton
al Sharpton the leading race fader of
the last 40 years in the United States a
man who suggested that Jews in New York
City were white interlopers a guy who
suggested that there were diamond
merchants a guy who nearly initiated
riot maybe initiated a riot in Crown
Heights in 1991 that ended in the death
of an Orthodox Jew he said about
Orthodox Jews there's an Orthodox Jew
who accidentally hit black kid with his
car and Al Sharpton said if they want to
fight why don't they pin on their
yarmulkes and come on over to my house
al Sharpton that piece of dreck okay
he's a bad guy Al Sharpton
that guy is sitting there talking about
the evils of Roseanne so I do have to
point out the media's double standard
here Roseanne should have lost her job
for reasons that I will explain in just
a second first of all it really should
requires no explanation that that
statement for a public figure you lose
your job end of story
but the media to refrain from pointing
out the double standard when joy Reid
who tweet out a bunch of other gross
stuff and Al Sharpton who is one of
race baiters in the history of the
United States at least in modern
American history to have those two
people commenting on it with Valerie
Jarrett who was targeted by Roseanne but
also happened to be a member of an
administration that was very happy too
polarizing along the basis of race it
provides a little bit of irony sitting
there alongside chris hayes who says
that all Trump supporters are basically
Roseanne hi anyway here is Valerie
Jarrett commenting on the situation well
first of all I think we have to turn it
into a teaching moment I'm fine
I'm worried about all the people out
there who don't have a circle of friends
and followers who come right to their
defense the person who's walking down
the street minding their own business
and they see somebody cling to their
purse or one across the street or every
black parent I know who has a boy who
has to sit down and have a conversation
but talk as we call it and those as you
say those ordinary examples of racism
that happen every single day okay so now
we get this routine where everybody is
Rosanna where America is replete with
Roseanne's where people in their back
room are tweeting out crazy stuff like
Roseanne Roseanne is a crazy person
Roseanne tweeted out that she was on
ambien and that's why she tweeted this
out which prompted ambien in pretty
hilarious fashion to tweet back one of
our side effects does not include racism
I'm good for ambien and it's true
whenever I saw the Zambian commercials I
never saw that butterfly with the KKK
hood on it that was just and I never
picked up on that but Valerie Jarrett
suggesting that we are all Roseanne is
the stupidest thing in the world
Roseanne's did something bad you know
what the effect was she lost her job she
lost a multi-million dollar job as the
top sitcom performer in the United
States and Valerie Jarrett is saying
this this somehow olympians the entire
United States somehow this is everyday
racism in America okay it's not everyday
racism in America because if it were
everyday racism in America Roseanne
wouldn't have lost her job I'm kind of
getting sick of this routine where we
smear the entire American public and all
Trump supporters with the brush of
Roseanne Barr
okay then joy read comments on Roseanne
is there's joy read again a woman who
tweeted out a bunch of really nasty
stuff like four weeks ago and then
recalled that she had amnesia she
literally claims she had amnesia which
is a plot line that went out of soap
operas in the 1980s she claimed that she
had amnesia she still has a job in she
gets to comment on Roseanne Barr here is
joy Reed on MSNBC commenting on it
see this is no big deal that this is
something that you should be able to say
why can't you say it well it's just
jokes why are people taking it too hard
that's part of the problem is that you
have a certain set of people who feel
that you should be able to speak this
way and unfortunately you know we have a
president at the moment who's kind of
giving a broad sense of permission to
not be politically correct to speak the
way you want to offend who you want and
that people really shouldn't have a
right to say anything about it okay this
is all this all straw man I didn't see
one major conservative commentator
yesterday saying Roseann should've kept
her job not one okay then the number of
conservative commentators who said
Roseann should have kept her job
it was relegated to like Jack cassabi AK
and maybe like a li like a couple of
guys who are really fringe and aren't
considered mainstream right figures in
any case but they're treating it as
though the entire right came out
swarming in defensive Roseanne Barr
obviously not true obviously not real
but the entire left did come out
swarming for joy Reid right so if you're
in if you're in entire one movement with
the actions of a bad person you might
want to tire the movement with the
person they actually defend so if you
want to say that Trump's base is willing
to defend his excesses that I agree with
but if you want to say that Trump's base
is willing to defend Roseanne Barr I
don't see Trump's base defending
Roseanne Barr today and the same thing
is not true of joy read the entire left
base came out in defense of joy read
very few of them wanted to I read to
lose her job the same thing is true of
Louis Farrakhan of Linda Sarsour
of a bunch of people keith Ellison who
have associated with the worst kinds al
Sharpton you know terrible terrible
people who have been defended repeatedly
by the left Roseanne Barr lost her job
after less than like four hours after
the suite came out so don't tell me the
entire right-wing base is supporting
Roseanne Barr it just ain't true and
Trump isn't even supporting Roseanne
Barr so al Sharpton again the idea the
media's gonna try out sharp into some
sort of great race relations expert is
just beyond it's beyond sickening here
is al Sharpton Loudon DeRozan
cancellation Roseanne has the right to
be a supporter of whatever politics she
wants but to take this kind of obvious
racial rhetoric to compare a learning
respected public service like valerie
jarrett to aa8 reminds us of all of the
history of blacks being called monkeys
and I think that Disney and ABC did the
right thing and I think they'll open the
door now
the other thing that they're doing okay
so there you are al sharpton leading
race baiter of our time commenting on
Roseann also apparently a race baiter
and one of them still has a job so it
does show you the double standard in the
media in just a second on and talk about
Van Jones response to all of this plus I
want to lay out some guidelines I think
for when firing is appropriate in
situations like this first I want to say
thanks to our sponsors over at us ECA so
we hear the stories all the time in the
news where a good guy uses a gun to
protect his family and then he's the one
who gets arrested
it does happen all the time because when
the police show up at a shooting they
don't really have a choice very often
they just arrest the person who's
standing over to the body even if that
person was the homeowner defending
themselves well thanks to the courts and
toxic policies the sort of stuff happens
way too often and that's what can happen
to you unless you are fully prepared so
here's what you should do start your
journey to complete concealed carry and
family defence confidence right now it
is easy with the u.s. ECAs complete
concealed carry and family defense guide
it is 100% free go to defend your family
now calm to get instant access right now
that's defend your family now calm for
that instant access in this packet this
concealed carry and family defense guide
you will learn how to detect attackers
before they see you how to survive a
mass shooting how to responsibly own and
store a gun even and especially if you
have small children a lot more it's 164
pages it comes with a complete audio
book so when you're done with my podcast
for the day you can listen in the car
this life changing guides 100% free but
only for a limited time plus you also
get their bonus home defense checklist
so go to defend your family now calm for
your 100% free copy again that's
defending your family now calm defend
your family now.com USC CA does
spectacular work in helping all
law-abiding gun owners to best know how
to use that weapon when to use that
weapon and to provide you the resources
you need if you have to indeed use that
weapon defend your family now got calm
to check them out okay so Van Jones to
was sounding off on the Roseanne
situation and he is blaming President
Trump for it obviously because President
Trump it's amazing everybody seems to
think that the universe revolves around
President Trump so Roseanne does
something bad and suddenly it has to do
with President Trump I'm not sure what
Roseanne has to do with Trump other than
Roseanne was a trump supporter but
Harvey Weinstein was a Hillary Clinton
supporter and I'm not sure why if Harvey
Miller er president right now I do not
think you'd see a lot of headlines about
Hillary supporter Harvey Weinstein goes
on in
you know is tried for rape I just don't
think that would be the headline now to
be a little bit fairer Roseann was
portraying a trump supporter on TV but
this was always the danger of her
portraying Trump supporter on TV I
mentioned at a time
I didn't nearly a full show on it I
talked about how Trump's portrayal of
Trump supporters was not helpful to
Trump supporters and that when you
tether your boat to crazy people bad
things happen as I said about Kanye West
likes it I'm happy Kanye wants to do the
open your mind thing but live by the
Kanye die by the Kanye live by the
Roseanne die by the Roseanne okay but in
any case here's Van Jones trying to try
to tide Trump to Rosanna's though Trump
was somehow using Rosanna's his meat
puppet like he had his hand in the back
of her head it was actually manipulating
her mouth to call Valerie Jarrett nabe
it could be that this moral collapse
inside of our political system
especially inside the White House is
being counterbalance now by people in
mainstream media mainstream corporations
say listen we don't want to live in a
country where you know decent people can
be attacked for no reason
within despicable terms and it's very
important enough it's not a joke it's
not funny okay so I agree it's not a
joke and I agree it's not funny to
pretend that Donald Trump is the person
who has laid our rhetoric low in
American public life is to ignore a lot
of American public rhetoric in the last
15 years I mean it was Joe Biden who in
2012 was going around saying that Mitt
Romney legitimately wanted to put y'all
back in Chains it was the Democratic
Party and within the last ten years was
producing videos of Paul Ryan throwing
old women off the edge of cliffs with
their wheelchairs so before we go to the
Donald Trump destroyed American rhetoric
a sentiment which I have some agreement
you do have to actually provide the
context for that destruction American
rhetoric and nobody including Trump was
saying that this kind of stuff was okay
right this is the Trump was not saying
that any of this stuff was okay Roseanne
Barr by the way went back on Twitter
later in the evening and started
tweeting out more random crazy stuff
again she blamed ambien and then she
claims that she didn't know that Valerie
Jarrett was black she said she thought
the Valerie Jarrett was white and Jewish
which makes no sense she accused her of
being a member of the Muslim Brotherhood
all of which demonstrates that maybe
Roseanne Barr is crazy
as I said repeatedly over and over but
now listen because I'm right okay so the
reason I say that you should listen is
because I'm gonna tell you
another celebrity situation inside the
Republican Party in just a second but
first I want to talk a little bit about
what should the standards be when people
actually get fired so there were two
very different two very different
stories that came out with regards to
corporate crackdowns on free speech over
the last couple of weeks last week we
had the big blow up because the NFL bans
kneeling during the national anthem on
the sidelines they said you want to stay
in the locker room go ahead and stay in
the locker room but if you come out of
the locker room and they're playing the
national anthem don't kneel or we're
gonna find you and people went nuts this
is a violation of First Amendment
freedoms this is a violation of the
spirit of free speech in America and you
know for myself I'm mildly uncomfortable
with the idea that the NFL is going to
force people to stand for the anthem but
as I said last week I think that
kneeling for the anthem is a stupid
counterproductive garbagey thing to do
is general rule and I also think that
the NFL has a right to defend its
product well this week the Rose Ann
thing happened and ABC immediately fired
Rose Ann and half the people who are
very angry at the NFL for barring people
from kneeling were very happy with ABC
for firing Rose Ann now obviously
kneeling for the anthem and calling a
black person an ape are not the same
thing Colin Kaepernick I will point out
didn't only kneel for the anthem he also
wore socks that that had cops depicted
his pigs on them so that wasn't exactly
a wonderful thing but the broader point
is is one that needs to be made and that
is when should we in the American public
be interested in the political
pronouncements and racist pronouncements
and gross pronouncements of public
figures when should we forgive them when
should we not when should they be fired
by companies and when should they not
and it seems to me that the line of
demarcation is when the speech that is
being used actually damages the product
of the corporation so here we're not
talking about the government getting
involved we're not talking about when
the government should crack down on
speech the answer is the government
should never crack down on speech the
government should not be arresting
roseanne barr for saying vile things the
question is when can a company when when
can a company fire roseanne and when is
it right to boycott Roseanne's show for
example or when is it right to boycott
the NFL and when can the NFL institute
new rules about kneeling and it seems to
me that when the product is connected
with the viewpoint then it is
appropriate to initiate a boycott and it
is also appropriate for a corporation to
respond in kind to that boycott so with
regard to the NFL the product that they
produced was a product that included the
national anthem on TV it was part of the
game the NFL is replete with patriotic
symbolism they use it all the time when
I was at the Super Bowl last year it was
fully patriotic and the video of the
Blue Angels fly over the whole thing so
if there if that is threatened and
people say listen I don't feel the same
way about that product as I used to
because the product itself has changed
that's not out of the realm of reality
or decency boycotting the NFL cuz you
don't like people kneeling for the
anthem seems to me well within the
bounds of normal public discourse the
same thing holds true for Rose in right
Roseanne even more so because Roseanne's
character is called Roseanne right the
show is based on Roseanne so if Roseanne
were playing a completely different
character I think you might even have a
more dicey situation so Matt Damon's has
a lot of really stupid things I don't
boycott Matt Damon's movies because in
Matt Damon's movies Matt Damon is not
playing Matt Damon Matt Damon is playing
whatever character he's playing on
screen so the product on screen has
nothing to do but the stupid crap Matt
Damon says off screen now there are
people who can't make that connection if
there are people who feel that every
time they see Matt Damon on screen it
reminds them of his dumb comments in the
past and so they don't want to see
whatever movie he's made this year
that's reasonable but I think that it's
a little bit over the top
the thing about Roseanne is that
Roseanne played Roseanne on TV her
character was supposed to mirror
Roseanne to a certain extent in real
life so for people to say I don't want
to watch a show with a lady who calls a
black lady up in ape I think that's
perfectly appropriate and it's perfectly
appropriate for ABC to crack down now
here's where it's not appropriate it's
not appropriate when you have somebody
like Brendan dice who is CEO of Mozilla
Firefox and Brendan dice was essentially
thrown out of his job because someone
initiated a boycott but because he had
once supported traditional marriage
because you have one supported
traditional marriage the reason that is
inappropriate is because mozilla
firefox' never discriminated against gay
people mozilla firefox' took no stance
on same-sex marriage
mozilla firefox is product had nothing
to do with same-sex marriage so it's
unreasonable to boycott mozilla firefox'
based on friends and aisha's personal
political beliefs okay and it is
inappropriate to boycott a church for
their for their beliefs if those beliefs
don't actually affect how they treat
people and it is inappropriate to
boycott a restaurant for those reasons
it is it for so chick-fil-a best example
okay Dan Cathy's the head of chick-fil-a
in favor of traditional marriage the
left launches massive boycotts against
Dan Cathy and chick-fil-a saying we
don't want to shop at that company
because that guy doesn't agree with us
on same-sex marriage what
same-sex marriage have to do with a
chicken burger the answer is nothing the
answer is nothing so in those cases
you're destroying the nature of free
speech the feeling of free speech in the
country when you make everything
political making everything political is
bad for the country but pretending that
everything is not political is just
unrealistic Rosen did something that
impacted the product shoes providing
kneeling for the anthem impacted the
proctor providing those are not the same
sort of impact obviously kneeling for
the anthem is not nearly as bad as
calling a black person an ape but is
insofar as do the corporations have the
the right on a moral level to fire
people for doing this or to set new
rules the answer of course is yes now
meanwhile president Trump has fired back
on the on the Rose Ann thing he just
couldn't help himself so he went all of
yesterday without commenting on it and I
was like yes this is great no mr.
president just stay out of it there's no
reason for you to get involved and then
you got involved because that's what the
President of the United States does so
you tweeted this out you tweeted out
quote Bob Iger of ABC called Valerie
Jarrett so let her know that ABC does
not tolerate comments like those made by
Roseanne Barr G he never called
President Donald J Trump to apologize
for the horrible statements made and
said about me on ABC maybe I just didn't
get the call only president Trump could
make this story about him only president
Trump could make a story about rosianna
insulting valerie jarrett about him i do
want to point out a couple of
distinctions here okay listen I don't
think Trump should have commented on
this thing in the first place I'm gonna
get to in a second Trump's relationship
with celebrity which i think is just
dumb but this is here's why this tweet
is stupid first valerie jarrett was
called an ape by the main star of Bob
iger's Network hey black person was
iger's Network he has to call Valerie
Jarrett Donald Trump was called a lot of
names on ABC but he was not called a
historically racist name applied to his
race yeah that's not if somebody called
him honky on ABC then I assume that Bob
Iger might have to call him but if they
were just saying they don't like Donald
Trump or he's an idiot or he's stupid or
he's garbage or whatever they were
calling Donald Trump like that's just
part of the public discourse honestly
and again I don't know what any of this
has to do with Trump Trump Trump's not
the victim here he's the President of
the United States I understand the main
point which is that there's a double
standard in the media and obvious
that is true about the double standard
in the media doesn't really extend to
Bob Iger having to call Trump every time
someone in Sultan plus I mean if we're
gonna talk about insulting people Donald
Trump is like the king of insulting
people has Donald Trump ever called Ted
Cruz to apologize for calling his wife
ugly publicly no did he ever call Alicia
Machado and apologize for basically
hyung or fatty in the middle of a
presidential campaign and suggesting
that she had a sex tape did he ever do
any of that no so it's like dude if he
you got to take it if you're gonna dish
it out like there's just my general
feeling on that particular on that
particular subject so I'm talking a
second about a big summit at the White
House but first honestly thanks to our
sponsors over an uncharted supply
company so this is the coolest thing
ever
uncharted supply company has designed a
survival system to help you out quickly
and confidently when the unexpected
happened 95% of all survival situations
are resolved in 72 hours but that leaves
you 72 hours where you need to survive
and that's what uncharted supply company
is for curated by survival experts the
72 survival system contains quality
tools and instructions you need to
survive in a hurricane earthquake or any
emergency situation all of the tools are
housed in a roll-top backpack that's so
airtight it can even be used as a
flotation device so just at our office
she is a big camper she loves camping
it's her it's her favorite thing to do
for some odd reason and she and her
boyfriend go camping all the time and so
she got one of these and she loves it I
mean she comes in and on at least a
weekly basis she talks about how good
the product here is there's a tent in it
apparently there's a flashlight that is
incredible the product itself is really
well-made and apparently it's pretty
lightweight as well so it's really
really great
and it's great not just if you are dying
in the middle of a clue like you got
stuck in a chasm and now you have to
chew your own arm off like 127 hours
it's not just good for that it's also
really good for if you just want to go
camping you're just out there in the
wild or you sticking them in your trunk
in case god forbid there's some sort of
emergency situation and you just carry
it around in there in case something
goes wrong that's what it's for
35 high-quality tools organized with
simple instructions each piece in the
kit has been vetted by experts including
military first responders mountain
guides doctors and more and the insert
not only organizes in color codes tools
by use case it also provides simple
instructions so it's organized by need
like food and water shelter and warmth
first-aid it only weighs like 12 pounds
is just fantastic it's first-rate right
now my listeners get 50 / 50 dollars off
at uncharted
my company comm uncharted supply co.com
when you use my promo code Shapiro at
checkout that's 50 bucks off your
survival system at Uncharted supply
co.com uncharted supply code comm when
you use my code Shapiro at checkout
again 50 bucks off coach Shapiro
uncharted supply cocom for $50 off
really an amazing product
okay so meanwhile I don't know what it
is with Republicans in celebrity that's
not true I do know what it is with
Republicans in celebrity what it is with
the Republicans in celebrity is that
Republicans are so often ripped on by
celebrities you know out here in Los
Angeles in Hollywood they spend so much
of their day being ripped on by people
out here that they get sad and then when
a celebrity comes forward and says I'm
with you everybody gets super excited oh
my gosh that famous persons with me and
it's it's fairly typical it's just a
human nature thing like when I was
growing up I remember that a big hero in
the Jewish community and still is with
Sandy Koufax
now Sandy Koufax is not a practicing Joe
Sandy Koufax is not somebody who spends
a lot of time thinking about Judaism
Sandy Koufax I believes intermarried but
Sandy Koufax one time took off a day of
Yom Kippur in the World Series and this
was a big move because Sandy Koufax is a
celebrity people are very very taken in
by celebrity the problem is a lot of
celebrities are celebrities for things
that have nothing to do with politics so
Roseanne was a celebrity because she's a
funny lady who's on a show in the 90s
those actually quite some left and the
same thing is true for Kanye West as I
say live by the Kanye die by the Kanye
I'm very glad that Kanye is saying that
people want to think for themselves but
Kanye is also Kanye and he is apt to say
things from time to time that may not be
politically the wisest you tie yourself
to a celebrity
Kid Rock who knows nothing about
politics and you shouldn't be surprised
when he burns you can't Republicans tied
themselves with celebrity in Donald
Trump and most of the things that have
burned them about Donald Trump have come
from him being a celebrity not from him
being the president it's been him
playing Celebrity Apprentice at the
White House or him during the campaign
saying celebrity like things right
that's that's where most of the trouble
for the Trump administration has come
not in his policies policies been quite
good and well now Donald Trump and Jared
Kushner and the White House they're
inviting over Kim Kardashian now why
they would invite Kim Kardashian I
suppose it's because yay we have a
celebrity and Kim Kardashian as close to
Kanye West and maybe
we maybe if we recruit some celebrities
then a lot of people will be warmer
toward us and we're showing that we're
reaching across the aisle and all the
rest Kim Kardashian okay let's just say
that the risk factor on Kim Kardashian
is not low and Kim Kardashian is not a
low risk figure she's not a person who
you have to the white house and then you
assume that she's gonna be a grand
spokesperson for your policies now I
understand Democrats could do this and
get away with it because they could
always hide one celebrity amidst the
thousands of other celebrities they had
Democrats are not tied to particular
celebrities in the same way that
Republicans are so Hillary Clinton was
not tied to Harvey Weinstein in the same
way that Donald Trump was sort of tied
to Roseanne in this particular case
because Harvey Weinstein was not one
among thousands of Hollywood celebrities
who supported Hillary Clinton there are
like five public celebrities who
supported Donald Trump and so Trump in
the public eye is very tied to each of
them well now he's having Kim Kardashian
to the White House and he's having Kim
Kardashian's in the White House to
discuss prison reform now I am really
luke cold on prison reform I am not in
love with with a lot of the talk about
prison reform the reason being that it
seems to me that the policy has not been
clarified in many cases the prison
reform they're talking about involves
letting people out of prison too early
and the recidivism rate among those
prisoners is like seventy five percent
over the course of the next five years
so letting people out of prison so they
can go back in prison seems not to make
a lot of sense to me now what people
have said is we're taking fewer people
into American prisons and the crime
rates aren't rising right because we
still have a lot of people in prison but
if you let more people out of prison the
crime rates rise we've seen this in the
state of California in the state of
California Jerry Brown has let thousands
of prisoners out of prison early on
prison furloughs and the crime rates
have gone up relatively dramatically in
most urban areas in the state of
California over the last several years
instead of building new prisons he
decided to release those people back to
county level and then those county level
prisoners were released into the general
public and it's been quite a disaster
well now the now the White House is
going to have Kim Kardashian over there
to talk about prison reform and
apparently she is interested in pushing
for she's interested in pushing for the
release of one particular prisoner named
Alice Johnson so who exactly is Alice
Johnson and why should she be released
the answer is that she shouldn't be
released and the answer is that Alice
Johnson is is a
person who is convicted of a major drug
offense in 1994 not just not just a
major drug offense like trafficking in
thousands of pounds of drugs and she's
being treated as though she's have
wronged innocence if you look at the
left-wing press today a lot of it is all
about how Alice Johnson is a wrongs'
innocence who ought to be released from
prison because now she's older and she's
wiser and she's a sweet nice old lady
and we ought to let her out well I mean
she was sentenced for a reason she's
given life in prison the reason that she
was given life in prison is because
Alice Johnson committed some pretty
terrible crimes so she just and she's
never admitted to committing these
terrible crimes by the way I love this
CNN printed a piece from her in early
May and in the editors note said this
Alice Marie Johnson is a grandmother who
has served more than 20 years in prison
for a first-time nonviolent offense so
that makes it sound like Alice Johnson
was smoking dope in her backyard and the
police came in and they arrested her and
then they gave her 20 years in prison
that is not what happened according to
Alice Johnson that is what happened
according to Alice Johnson she says I'm
only one of thousands of first-time
nonviolent offenders even mandatory and
lengthy prison terms after committing
crimes under financial distress in 1996
I was given a death sentence without
sitting on death row I was convicted as
a first-time nonviolent drug offender to
life behind bars in federal prison since
I went to prison the laws governing my
wrongdoing have changed if I were
convicted again today for the same crime
my life might look very different and
then she wrote she's written some plays
and she supposedly made herself she's
supposedly made herself into a better
human being and all of this just before
my incarceration I had a full life I
married my childhood sweetheart and make
him muttered of mother to five beautiful
children as the years went on I became a
facilitator training people on how to be
managers I was manager at FedEx for
seven years life for a time was good
I'll tell you the rest of Alice
Johnson's a tragic saga in just one
moment but first I want to say thanks to
our sponsors over at policy genius so
80% of people think life insurance costs
double what it actually costs okay life
insurance is affordable and there's no
excuse for you not to get it and it
doesn't have to be time-consuming either
you don't have to spend all your time on
the phone with life insurance agents
trying to sell you something instead
just go over to policy genius calm and
check them out it's the easy way to
compare life insurance online in just
five minutes you can compare quotes from
the top insurers to find the best policy
for you so that if you die you don't
have to leave your family bereft policy
genius has helped over 4 million people
shop for insurance they placed over
20 billion dollars in coverage and they
don't just make life insurance easy
they also compare disability insurance
renter's insurance and health insurance
if you care about it they can cover it
so if you've been thinking about getting
life insurance go to policy genius.com
these are the folks who can get you the
best price on life insurance and they
can check it all out for you in just a
couple of minutes it's the easy way to
compare the top insurers and find the
best policy you will be saving time
money and hassle and it's free so
there's no reason not to do it policy
genius so pause wherever your listening
pause government policy genius right now
and check it out policy genius calm
comparing life insurance does not need
to be a pain in the neck again no reason
to leave your family in the lurch if god
forbid you die just spend five minutes
now take care of it you never have to
worry about it again so I'm gonna tell
you the rest of Alice Johnson's story
and why it is that all the talk about
her being released from prison seems a
little bit like a fib in just a second
first we're gonna have to go over to
daily wire calm so for $9.99 a month you
get the rest of this show live you get
to hear the rest of the show live and
reclaim the show live Michael Mills is
show live all of these wonderful
glorious things you also get early
capacity VIP tickets when we have our
events so and then we have our events
and we're having one in Dallas one in
Phoenix that VIP tickets are all sold up
you could have been one of the first
person to get one of the first people to
get them if you had actually had a
subscription to daily wire comm for $99
a year you get all of that gets be part
of my mail bag plus you get this the
very greatest in all beverage vessels
this leftist Cheers hot or cold tumbler
I refuse to bring it on the road because
it was too precious to me I could not do
it I had to leave it here we have it in
a glass case we break only in case of
emergency or advertising so we took it
out today and now I'm advertising it to
you but you can have one of these and
you can sip leftist cheers at all times
of the day however you choose to do so
$99 a year annual subscription also
check us out at iTunes SoundCloud
YouTube subscribe to this review we
always appreciate it and check out our
daily wire app over at the at the Apple
news app check out the daily wire news
we always have great news breaking over
there we are the largest fastest core
and conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so to return to our story as you recall
Kim Kardashian the Trump administration
they're all pushing for Alice Johnson to
be released from prison again there is a
problem here the problem is that Alice
Johnson actually committed a pretty dire
crime she says she did not she says
after almost two decades together and
it's multiple relationship my husband
and I divorced in 1989 was during this
time my life began to spiral out of
control I lost my job and then my
youngest son was tragically killed in a
motorcycle accident no mother should
have to bury her child this weight was
unbelievable and it was a burden I
couldn't sustain I made some very poor
decisions out of desperation I want this
part to be clear I acknowledge that I
have done wrong I made the biggest
mistake of my life to make two ends meet
and got involved with people selling
drugs this is a road I never dreamed of
venturing down I became what is known as
a telephone mule passing messages
between distributors and sellers I
participated in a drug conspiracy and I
was wrong
okay so that makes it sound like she
made some phone calls right if you just
read that story she made a few phone
calls if you read it the left to impress
then that's all that she did here is the
actual AP story from when Alice Johnson
was sentenced okay for this is from 1997
quote a 41 year old Memphis woman was
sentenced to life in prison for leading
a multi-million dollar drug ring that
dealt in tons of cocaine from 1991 to
1994 Alice Marie Johnson was quote the
quintessential entrepreneur said US
District Judge Julia Gibbons as she
pronounced sentence on Friday and
clearly the impact of 2,000 to 3,000
kilograms of cocaine in this community
is very significant Johnson was tried
last year on cocaine conspiracy and
money laundering charges along with
Curtis McDonald and cherlene McNeil
during the trial evidence showed an
operation with Texas based Colombian
drug dealers and their Memphis
connections trading tons of cocaine for
millions of dollars in cash McDonald's
was sentenced earlier this month to life
in prison for his part in the cocaine
conspiracy and money laundering
operation McNeil received a 19 year
sentence so no this was not like she was
just sitting on the corner selling some
pot she was running thousands of pounds
of cocaine from a Columbian base to drug
cartel amen I'm gonna get that in the
press all of which is to say maybe you
want to release her from president maybe
you want a parole or maybe you think
that she's done her time she's been in
prison since 1997
so she's been there for 21 years at this
point maybe you think that she should be
released into the general public that's
fine I don't know why you would do it
based on Kim Kardashian's
recommendation and I don't know why you
would take celebrity seriously on these
issues in the first place since there
are not experts on these issues in the
first place it irritated the living hell
out of me when Barack Obama had George
Clooney in she talked about Middle
Eastern policy and it drives me nuts
when the Trump administration has Kim
Kardashian in to discuss prison reform
I'm sorry there is no level of expertise
that Kim Kardashian or George Clooney
seem to have it's one thing if you wanna
talk to Amal Clooney right Amal Clooney
apparently actually has some expertise
used to work at the UN but you want to
talk to people who actually know what
they are talking about I am not sure
what Kim Kardashian has expertise on
other than branding she's great at
branding no question she makes emojis so
there's that so I guess if there's an
emoji summit at the White House then we
can have Kim Kardashian in but I hate
celebrity worship it drives me up a wall
I've lived my entire life in LA
surrounded by people who worship
celebrity it is so stupid I cannot even
tell you most celebrities do not know
what they are talking about most
celebrities are not politically aware
most celebrities are at best
tangentially involved with politics but
because they're famous we think they
know everything the halo effect in the
in the human psyche and the human psyche
is really an amazing thing it really is
an amazing thing the the halo effects
which suggests that because somebody is
good at one thing this means they are
good at all things it's pretty amazing
that so we think that because somebody
is beautiful this means they're smart or
because they are rich it also means that
they are wise okay none of this is true
you can be rich and stupid
you can be beautiful and stupid you can
be smart and ugly all of these things
can be true at once or it can be rich
and stupid and ugly right any
combination of these factors is possible
but because human beings tend to worship
at the altar of fame they say okay I see
that guy I know that person that person
must know what they're talking about so
Kim Kardashian must obviously know what
she is talking about Kim Kardashian I
don't know why you would think she knows
what she is what she's talking about I
just wouldn't know meanwhile well we're
having summits at the White House while
we're on summits to the White House on
prison reform while we're spending time
on prison reform at the White House with
Kim Kardashian and spending our time
talking about spending our time talking
about the the situation regarding
Roseanne it turns out that 5,000 people
died in Puerto Rico did you know that
were you aware of this okay like this is
an actual thing so we were told there
was a couple of dozen
people who died in the in Hurricane
Maria turns out not according to the
Washington Post Milly on amantani
Montana has cradled her mother's head as
she lay dying on the floor of her
bedroom here gasping Farrar pleading for
help
there was nothing her family could do it
took 20 minutes to find cellular
reception to make a 911 call an
operative traffic signal slowed down the
ambulance struggling to reach their
neighborhood through crippling
congestion more than eight months after
Hurricane Maria devastated Puerto Rico
the island slow recovery has been marked
by a persistent lack of water a
faltering power grid and a lack of
essential services all imperiling the
lives of many residents especially the
enfermo in remote areas hardest hit in
September the new harvest study
published on Tuesday in the New England
Journal of Medicine estimates that at
least 4645 deaths can be linked to the
hurricane and it's mediate aftermath
making the storm far deadlier than
previously thought official estimates
have placed the number of dead at 64
account that has drawn sharp criticism
from experts so they're only off by a
factor of 70 whoops
okay the Harvard findings indicate that
healthcare disruption for the elderly
and the loss of basic utility services
for the chronically ill had significant
impacts and the study criticized Puerto
Rico's methods for counting the dead and
its lack of transparency and sharing
information as detrimental to planning
for future natural disasters the authors
called for patients communities and
doctors to develop contingency plans for
such disasters so more people were
killed by Hurricane Maria according to
this hurricane according to this Harvard
study then were killed in 9/11 by a
factor of about 50% and yet nobody is
talking about that today we are all too
busy talking about Kim Kardashian at the
White House and the fact that Roseanne
said something racist and mean to
Valerie Jarrett
maybe our priorities in this country are
a little bit screwed up researchers in
the mainland United States in Puerto
Rico led by scientists at the Harvard th
Chan School of Public Health and Beth
Israel Deaconess Medical Center
calculated the number of deaths by servi
a surveying almost 3300 randomly chosen
households across the island and
comparing the estimated post-hurricane
death rate to the mortality rate for the
year before their surveys indicated the
mortality rate was fourteen point three
deaths per 1000 residents from September
20th through December 31st 2017 a 62
percent increase in the mortality rate
compared with 2016 or 406 4645 excess
deaths now that's probably a little bit
exact it could be 5000 it could be 3,000
but it is not 60 for a lot of people
have died because the government has
done a terrible job of restoring
they need to in Puerto Rico and that is
both the fault of the federal government
and it is also the fault of the local
government in Puerto Rico which is a
protectorate of the United States
obviously Carlos Mercado who's executive
director of the Puerto Rican federal
affairs administration said in a
statement on Tuesday that the
territorial government welcomes the new
Harvard study and looks forward to
analyzing it
okay well I'm sure that they do but
again our priorities in this country
really need to change we are we are
attracted to the shiny bauble celebrity
attracts us to the shiny bauble and
listen we all like discussing the
cultural issues because we can all have
an opinion but these are the areas where
government really needs to be go to
things and government is just not good
at these things and it seems to me we
should be spending an awful lot more
time talking about bipartisan failures
to help alleviate the problems in Puerto
Rico then we should be talking about Kim
Kardashian's priorities with regard to a
woman who's been in jail for 20 years
for trafficking in thousands of pounds
of cocaine or Rosanne bars mean comments
about Valerie Jarrett okay so we just
won't have a revive Roseanne said come
next year seems to me like that's less
important as a general matter than the
number of people who died in Puerto Rico
because of this hurricane okay well in
just a second I want to talk a little
bit about the the Eric Greitens
resignation in the state of Missouri so
Eric Greitens is the governor of
Missouri or was the governor of Missouri
until late last night last night Eric
Greitens made an announcement he would
no longer be the governor of Missouri
because he was caught up in the sex
scandal where he having affair with a
lady and she alleged that he tied her up
and naked and then took pictures of her
it sounds like it delight so Eric
Greitens resigned yesterday this ordeal
has been designed to cause an incredible
amount of strain on my family millions
of dollars of mounting legal bills
endless personal attacks designed to
cause maximum damage to family and
friends and it's clear that for the
forces that oppose us
there is no end in sight I cannot allow
those forces to continue to cause pain
and difficulty to the people that I love
okay so he should have gotten out of
here a lot earlier what took him months
to do it there's this feeling in
American politics right now that the
longer you hold on
the better the chance that you're going
to survive right Al Franken announced
that who's gonna resign and then he had
to resign very quickly if he had held on
for a few more weeks he'd probably still
be in the United States Senate Eric
Greitens felt like if he somehow was
able to hold on then he would be able to
retain his job despite all of the
allegations that have been made against
him via the the charges against him are
still pending and they may be refil all
of which is to show there was a lot of
talk in the aftermath of president
Trump's election about the change in the
mindset of the American people that the
American people were willing to spend
there they're willing to go along with
anything politicians were willing to do
so long as those politicians gave them
what they wanted I don't think that's
actually true I think that President
Trump is in many ways one off I think
President Trump won the presidency
because Hillary Clinton was deeply
unpalatable to a huge number of
Americans and because of that they're
willing to look the other way a little
bit at his excesses but if you ask most
Americans do they actually like the
excesses of President Trump they would
say no they like how president from
treats women the answer probably for
most Republicans is no does that mean
they don't like his policies it doesn't
mean that either but they see Donald
Trump as a tool now here's the way that
it works in politics the more power you
have the more you are able to get away
with this is unfortunate truth again
about human nature if you are a dog
catcher you can get away with nothing
because we can easily replace you I mean
easily replace you with something else
well the truth is that you can easily
will replace the president with the vice
president but in terms of his cultural
impact in terms of his appeal in terms
of the damage that he can do on a
cultural level that is certainly not
true for president Trump who's a much
more powerful cultural figure than vice
president pence for example so as you
elevate the amount of power somebody has
we are willing as human beings to allow
those people to get away with more
things but that willingness is not
infinite and so Eric Greitens is just a
governor of Missouri and who can easily
replace by another Republican for
governor of Missouri which is what will
happen he can go away without having a
significant impact on the Republicans in
the state or the conservative agenda in
the state the same is not really true
for president Trump in a lot of ways and
so that's why there have been so many
people who have been willing to kind of
brush off president Trump's excesses in
a way that they wouldn't be willing to
for Eric Greitens is that right it
probably isn't right is it realistic
yeah that's realistic I mean that's just
the way that the human mind works now
speaking of the presidential race coming
up in 2020 good news for Democrats
Bernie Sanders is there display
Hardy again a former Bernie Sanders
spokesperson says don't worry he's gonna
run again in 2020
hey will voters get another chance to
vote for Bernie Sanders in 2020
well voters in Vermont certainly well
coming up in November nationally you
know he is considering another run for
the presidency and you know when the
time comes I think we'll have an answer
that but right now he's he's still
considering he'd be a fool not to run in
2020 considering how splintered the
Democratic Party is he actually has a
serious shot at winning the nomination
in 2020 now it's hard to capture the
magic twice as Ross Perot learned in
1996 that said who's gonna be out there
against him Kamala Harris come on Harris
thinking take votes away from Bernie
Sanders Elizabeth Warren she's not gonna
take votes away from Bernie Sanders
Bernie Sanders has 30 percent of the
Democratic Party base locked down behind
him and that's enough to win right he
could run a very Trump like primary
campaign in 2020 and seize the
nomination that way unless Democrats
rally around a Joe Biden desk figure so
Bernie Sanders is a serious threat for
the nomination so we could in fact in a
Trump Sanders race in 2020 and wouldn't
that be something my goodness so much
putting so much pudding so we can all
look forward to that oh happy happy day
our politics can get even dumber that'll
be just an awesome okay time for some
things I like and then some things I
hate so things I like so there's a book
by a guy named Gary Sol Morrison Gary
Sol Morrison is a great favorite of my
new brother-in-law I was out of town
over the weekend as my sister got
married and Gary Sam Morrison was was at
the wedding he is a really terrific
thinker and a great literary analyst and
he has a book called Anna Karenina in
our time seeing more wisely so you sort
of have to have read Anna Karenina in
order to get the book so go out and buy
a copy of Anna Karenina and when you're
done reading it come back in six months
then read this book but but Anna
Karenina of course one of the great
novels in in the history of mankind
and this book is really about how people
miss read Anna Karenina as a story of
failed female empowerment when what the
story really is about is about failure
to abide by commitment attempts to hide
from your true nature attempts to find
romantic love in place of affectionate
love and it's it's it's got some really
deep thoughts on the human condition
that are not necessarily completely
apparent from reading Anna Karenina when
you read Anna Karenina people tend to
read it as sort of as sort of a not bad
Mansa novel but as a as a an over overly
long romance novel with Anna Karenina
who's having an affair and then she
kills herself at the end by throwing
herself under the Train 200 years later
spoiler alert but it's in but the this
story is really not about that that that
ignores at least two-thirds the actual
plot and and the other characters in the
story like Altima story novels Anna
Karenina is sprawling I mean really
sprawling covers a lot of ground but
Gary Psalm Orson does a wonderful job of
leaving all those strands back together
so go check it out Anna Karenina in our
time it's really a fun read if you're
into if you're in the literature okay
time for it some things that I hate so I
just have to feel really bad for this
dude so the he this is a picture of a
dude who is crushed a couple thousand
years ago so Pompeii right remember this
big volcano
this guy's scape the volcano then a
giant rock fell on his head so yesterday
his body was discovered he had the
second worst day after Roseanne
yesterday this guy so that that's just
you know and and the good news for him
is he will leave on he will live on in
me mystery forever the nature of those
pictures no oh man his last thing you
know the last thing that went through
his head was that rock that's that's
just that's terrible oh what a terrible
story you know what I have to revert I
forgot again I was gonna do it yesterday
a quick thing that I like and then I'll
go back to some more things that I hate
so on on Monday evening
I had a chance to meet with Nikki Haley
so Mike might actually have to meet my
spirit animal so the world did not
implode when I met my spirit animal
nikki Haley at the UN I did in fact meet
the UN ambassador nikki Haley and I met
her son who's an awesome kid a Nalin who
listens to the show and it was just it
was great it was a blast
so I just wanted to give a shout out to
ambassador Haley as well as mostly Nalin
who's a really great kid and really
politically active and doing great work
out there and that was a blast that was
that was really cool just wanted to just
want to note that okay now back to
things I hate says it does enough liking
things her back things I hate so there
was a video that was going around the
internet of this black woman ranting at
a Jewish man on a subway
okay this was going around the internet
because it's really quite incredible got
tweeted out said this is what it's like
to be on the subway in New York here is
a little bit of
[Music]
okay so here's what happened in this
video pretty crazy video what happened
this video is a black woman got on them
on the subway with three kids and nobody
stood up firm and this guy this Jewish
guy was already standing and a second
black woman started chiding the people
in the in the subway for not standing up
for the black woman then she said if
this were a Jewish family getting on
you'd stand up which she has no evidence
for my guess is that people wouldn't
stand up I've been on subways with
Jewish families a lot of people don't
stand up okay this happens all the time
people in New York are incredibly rude
that's I think sorry break it to you but
that's your reputation and so this
Jewish guy says well that's kind of
racist like why are you saying that
they'd stand up for a Jewish family but
not for a black family then she says no
Jews are racist because you won't rent
to us and then he says well why don't
you stop talking about groups and just
talk about you like as an individual
talk about you and me and says well
we're not the same we're not individuals
so there are a couple of notes that I
have about this video so note number one
is people say vile things all the time
and very few people are willing to stand
up and say something good for this
Jewish guy for saying something when
this lady started ranting in racist
fashion about Jews second of all we're
all the other people on the subway so
well all this is going on apparently
people still don't stand up to actually
get up and let the kids sit down and
second of all nobody on the subway
actually says to the lady listen calm
down this has nothing to do with group
politics or racism maybe you should cut
that out and when people stop acting out
of decency and start acting out of a
sense of entitlement
it's things get really ugly and when
people sit there and allow it to go
forward things get even uglier there's
there's this this great movie and I'm
trying to remember I've recommended it
on the show before it's about a it's on
it takes place on a subway it takes
place on
New York subway it's called the incident
that's what it's called and it has this
big cast as Beau Bridges and Ruby Dee
and Jack Gilford Nagma Ed McMahon and
Brock Peters and Thelma Ritter and Jan
sterling and the the basic premise of
the film is that these two criminals get
onto a subway car and then start
harassing one-by-one the passengers on
the car and people aren't able to get
and people are not able to stand up to
them the only person who's willing to
stand up to them is Beau Bridges who
plays a soldier on the car things have
not changed since 1967 ok the same thing
is happening on subways today because
again it is human nature I talk a lot
about human nature today but it is
indeed human nature for a lot of folks
to to believe that they're better off if
they just sit there and allow bad things
to happen in front of them ok final
thing that I hate Trevor Noah
who as I've said has been in a running
gun battle with Samantha B and Amy
Schumer is on this list and Lena Dunham
is also on this list for at least funny
person in America so Trevor Noah was on
CNN again amazing how CNN will give
Trevor Noah all sorts of room to run
with regard to his political viewpoints
even though he's just a comedian of
course and he comes out he says Trump is
right for comedy and Obama is not that's
why we make fun of Trump all the time
you it cannot be more apparent like one
is right for comedy one is for instance
Donald Trump has left no contradiction
unturned that's his thing Donald Trump
is a gift to every level of comedy if
you want to you know apply comedy or
satire at the lowest level Donald Trump
is rife put that you don't have to dig
deeper but if you do dig deeper you will
get more from him as well you know Obama
was like many politicians a water table
that is very far belief beneath the
surface so to get to the right joke and
the right piece of satire that would
really luminate what Obama's didn't get
to dig through so many layers and work
through the weeds to get to the water
table of jokes now so this is actually
not true ok so here's the truth about
about comedy Trump isn't inherently
funnier person than Barack Obama and no
question I mean the guy's funny like the
whole thing's hilarious like the day he
was elected the night he was elected
there's a tape of me laughing for 2
straight minutes when someone calls and
President Donald Trump cuz it's just
funny the whole situation is hilarious
but in terms of what you can get better
a comedy out of the truth is the easy
comedy is not always the best comedy
mure seeing this on a sand
where they're going for low-hanging
fruit and they're failing on a routine
basis where Alec Baldwin his impression
of Donald Trump is not particularly
funny
because he doesn't like Donald Trump
because it's too easy to kind of mock
Donald Trump for being Donald Trump the
truth is that the pretensions of Barack
Obama were ripe for comedy Barack Obama
was the most pretentious jerk in in the
in the Oval Office in a long time a guy
who really thought he was above it all
this he thought he's the sort of Jesus
asked figure and he really wasn't right
he was he was a selfie stick president
there's a lot of potential for comedy
that it's just that folks on the Left
don't think Barack Obama is funny
because they see him the same way Omaha
sees himself that was the big problem
Obama saw himself as this grand unifying
Jesus figure and so did the people in
Hollywood so they saw no way to make a
joke can't make a joke about Jesus when
you believe in him right so the same
thing is true for Barack Obama not true
of Trump they don't like Trump but that
means that their comedy ain't all that
funny about Trump it's usually them just
making a face into camera and look how
stupid Trump is that's not inherently
funny what's inherently funny is the
ridiculous I am above it nature of
Barack Obama they could have been played
for laughs if any of these people
bothered to actually make a move in that
direction they weren't ever gonna make
that move the it's it's you know again I
think very silly that the comedic world
has suddenly rediscovered it's funny
bonus in his Trump became president
there's plenty to laugh at in the Obama
administration for sure okay we'll be
back here tomorrow with all the latest
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah
of era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire Ford publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018